throughout history different cultures
all over the world
reference a great tournament to fight
for something known
as mortal kombat my first question is
for you you know you play
a new character so was there any mortal
kombat character that wasn't in the
movie that you took
inspiration from uh no i wasn't inspired
by
any mortal kombat previous character i
was inspired by the game itself the
energy of the game
um you know i'm a big fan of the game i
was playing it when i was a kid
and i think uh there's a creativity
there's a power there's a there's a
fantasy element to it there's a
brutal element to it but there's also a
beauty element to it and i think that um
the energy of the game is what inspired
me and then as a as an actor who's
who uh loves martial arts and loves to
perform my martial arts
um it was a an opportunity for me to
showcase something and
and to uh to represent um you know for
asian americans
in a way that maybe hasn't been done in
many years so uh
i was proud of that moment and there was
a lot of pressure but
it was also a great opportunity well you
rose to the occasion because i can't
thank you
to learn this new character it's very
very exciting
um mccod for you i feel like your
character uses a very specific
fighting approach i was hoping you could
talk to us about that because it seems
very like brute force so what was the
specific fighting approach
um we we so we worked with this
incredible uh sensei called
uh amino am i saying his last name right
pinta
you know so pilaf sorry i always mess it
up
milo pila and he's a incredible guy who
was able to i think he knows 20 some odd
fighting styles so like
you know we we were like looking at
jackson i was playing the game and we're
trying to figure out exactly what his
fighting style is and he's he's an army
boxer which is like
just just brute force he's a bruiser um
he's the kind of guy who doesn't like i
was i would post videos of of of of
of training and people like oh get your
hands up like no that's not jax
he doesn't care if you hit him you can
hit him
he's gonna if he but he's but if he hits
you it's over you understand like
so like that's what he's focused on like
he doesn't mind taking a couple punches
here and there because when he when he
punches you it's over it's done
and so like we i just really i i did a
lot i watched a lot of footage on
uh joe frazier a lot of footage on mike
tyson
the like who who were the brute forces
who were the bruisers
uh who were the best and these these two
um were were suggested to me and and
i kind of stole my physicality from
those two and then also jax from the
game
he bounces a lot he's got a rhythm he's
got a movement and he
he bounces on his approach and uh and
he's and he dodges well
so uh we we i think i think we came up
with something that was cool
you did i mean it's so cool hearing your
process too and like who you were
pulling the inspiration from because now
hearing it like you can see it now when
i think back to the performance
so that's so cool um one thing i wrote
down when i was
watching the film and this question is
for both of you um
especially you though louis i feel like
you get hurt
your character gets hurt so much in the
film how do you make it believable
like if someone like pretended to hit me
i'd be like oh but like i wouldn't
know how to like actually make it look
like i was hurt so how do you guys make
that believable
well nas it was a very simple process
because uh
it was real most of the time i mean look
obviously obviously you know i'm not
getting punched in the face all day but
yeah there's definitely
a physical element to it uh there's
definitely a lot of
uh times when you you know have these
accidents and there's times when they're
not accidents and you have to just take
a shot
and that's just what it is and um you
know we we do our best
as performers to uh create an
environment that's safe but also
um you know as there's certain
choreography
certain types of choreography and
certain moves that uh are gonna be
painful and that just comes with the
process but
i use it into my character like you said
thank you for for noticing that
um because uh i was we shot from
beginning to end
in order and as i was continuously going
through this film and shooting these
action scenes i was continuously
more and more exhausted and more and
more sore
and injuries and that's what the
character was going through so
fortunately it worked out lewis has
had more fight scenes than i did and um
he had some you know i think i think
that there was
there was more costume involved in mine
more special effects involved
particularly towards the end of the
movie but i mean i
uh i sometimes i got hurt watching lewis
fight it was crazy
like like i was like oh my chin hurts
this is crazy
i know but it's like when you watch
something on the screen you're like ow
yeah speaking of like speaking of
special effects i wanted to ask
you lewis like what were you actually
fighting when you are fighting goro in
the film
like what were you playing against that
was me i was me
covered i was in blue paint because you
know
they needed somebody huge you know what
i'm saying so yes mackard's right they
needed somebody huge
and um there was a stunt man my friend
benny who uh
was on stilts and so there's this giant
man on stilts
and connected to his arms are these
other huge pieces of uh
what it's like a kind of like the
material that you would use for like
boxing mitts
boxing pads like like a like a muay thai
pad
and uh he had that as an extension and
he had this big old thing on his head
and then he had another amazing stuntman
underneath him
to play the other two arms so when i was
fighting these two guys
it was i mean it was something that i've
never done before because not usually
i'm memorizing choreography with two
hands versus two hands and two feet
versus two feet
you know and i can see what punches are
coming and i know when i take the hit i
know how to react
in this case i'm fighting and my two
hands could be up here
but i'm getting hit down here so i gotta
do choreography up here
and reactions down here and then i gotta
do reaction up here and choreography
down here
and so it's like it was a really crazy
process
and then um after that is finished i
have to do the exact same choreography
the exact same way with nobody there
because uh that's
the for the process of the visual
effects they need that
what you call a ghost plate to showcase
the movements i'm doing without anybody
there so we do it there so i can i can
get into the feel of it
and then they leave the frame and i do
it with nobody the exact same way
this is insane i hope that that footage
like gets like rotated on tick tock one
day like the actual footage did you play
mortal kombat growing up and if so who
was your favorite character to play at
yeah we i i definitely played mortal
kombat growing up but my favorite
characters to play with
were scorpion and jax in that order
yeah i played the game too uh i played
it as a kid religiously
um i started off with liu kang and then
now i play with
kung lao and and smoke
thanks jax
what was it like being cast as one of
the most recognizable
characters in mortal kombat well it felt
like my
entire childhood just made sense in that
instance
you know all my all my quarters hard
earned allowance
all that time well wasted all the
sneaking around with my second genesis
while my mom wasn't around doing the
fatalities
that all made sense that all came true
yeah
and then to share that with the world
and to share that there's to see that
there are so many fans that feel
exactly the same way it's a real
it's real cathartic and vindication i
think um
yeah i got pretty emotional when i got
the part
uh not only because it's mortal kombat
but also because it's
you know my first uh main role in such a
big hollywood film so i was overwhelmed
by
the chance and the whole situation and
um
yeah i right away went into preparation
um
that's how it started but
i love mortal kombat we all have mortal
kombat
you guys have you seen this movie and if
you have
what do you think of your scenes because
if i was either of you i would walk away
just feeling like the ultimate badass
there's look we we filmed so much
especially the fights there's probably
enough fight footage to do 10 mortal
kombat movies
uh i think they took the sensuality um
and made it
into the final cut which is which is
really nice and gratifying
um i really wanted the relationship
between
liu kang and kung lao to show through
because i think they're
like the yin and the yang they're
dependent on each other and
you know i don't think that the story
uh is finished there as we know in
mortal kombat
there's 18 realms and we just travel
between them and i can't see what the
next incarnation is
wow what about you max have you seen the
scenes and what did you think
it being your first major film uh yeah i
mean we
all watched it together in in a cinema
in
sydney but that was not the finish
finished
version but however i was already like
blown away by that one
and then recently i saw the new one the
final one with all the vfx and
the music added into it and i mean simon
the director
they all just did such a great job i was
i was blown away because i didn't expect
it to be that good so yeah
kung lao has like some wild scenes i
wanted to know max like what are you
actually throwing instead of the razor
rimmed hat
like what were you actually doing in
those scenes well
uh in some occasions it is the real hat
it is the real hat um but other times we
had like a blue
kind of uh lighter version
of the hat that that i would throw and
then it would be
replaced by the vfx and um
um yeah sometimes i probably didn't have
any hat at all
just ma max and i i met like nine years
ago
so we're we're old friends yeah we met
on a movie called um
i'm sorry i love you in china and then
so when we found out that we're gonna be
playing an hollywood movie together
he sent me what he was repairing and he
started preparing a long time as soon as
he got casted
and so he's in the stunt gym in jackie
chan stunt gym in china
throwing away this cardboard hat that he
made
for himself and it looked amazing and a
lot of that stuff
that you actually see in the movie is
stuff that he
actually choreographed for himself so
fantastic
wow that's mind-blowing it's honestly i
can't wait for the world to see it
because it's so good
you obviously said you played mortal
kombat as a child i wanted to know which
characters did you guys both play and
why
uh i i've played luke gang a lot because
i think he's unfairly powerful
he just dedicates himself to those like
three moves you know the bicycle kick
the dragon fire and the
and and like the long kick and the sweep
the super cheap sweep that everybody
hates
um but i like liu kang and i like
sub-zero because it's like fire and ice
i i also have i have to admit i played
liu kang probably more than i played
kung lao
uh just because i didn't know too much
about
kung lao like back then when i was a
child but
i always knew about liu kang for some
reason i mean he was modeled
um to the looks of of bruce lee so i
always
had a strong um admiration for
for bruce lee so that's probably why i
chose to play liu kang but i also like
sub-zero and um
and lately i enjoy playing kung lao
right all the way baby
when we got there it tore through our
unit in seconds
in this film is it weird having to
pretend that things are like coming
out of your hands like what are you
playing to
well when we were shooting it and the
ice wasn't there for sure i
have to use all the fantasy and
imagination to
become like you know for the first time
i saw the movie i was like oh
and then you can realize with
particularly what they want to go
but the funnest thing when i project
when we were shooting i project what's
going to be the force how it's going to
look like
when i watch the movie somehow it's just
synchronized it's just it's just crazy
so it's just showing that you have the
same you're on the same path with the
filmmaker
for the people involved in the movie so
that's that's magical that's magical i
gotta say
it is magical you can tell on screen but
what like what are you playing to were
you holding anything like when were you
no nothing yeah i think uh everything
you just
i think i hold nothing it just it just
put in my mind that it's there and then
the vfx guy
is just kind of checking how big the
sword is going to be
and how long and then how you how when
you're going to hold it so
they kind of we're going to we work
together to find like
the best collect momentum so for them
too
because they're going to put everything
in a post-production so
without disturbing me without disturbing
my performance so it was it was it was
crazy
that they did that because yeah i just
did my part
i do everything my part i did all my
part without
like you know get the distraction from
them that you got to do it this way or
that way
so they just you know kind of like
follow and then resonate it
with the with the performance that's
pretty amazing you know it's incredible
how you're able to do it it must feel so
weird just
going like this to nothing you know but
you're a world champion
fighter joe so can you talk about your
specific fighting style and how you
brought that to sub-zero
well i used to be a judo judo athlete
for 12 years
and then well in judo we didn't really
punch and kick mostly it's just wrestle
and ground fighting so i
learned everything from zero i learned
everything uh
one movie to another just train with the
choreographers but i believe
that martial arts is like music you know
when you're
really good in one particular instrument
to jump to another instrument
it's just a matter of different outfit
but what's inside is the same so martial
arts is the same
so i'm a judo guy for half of my life
and when i jump to
in the raid like silad or in warrior
a kung fu master like in this motor
combat i play
like ancient martial arts like chinese
martial arts
that it's the same core it's the same
rhyme but it's just different
outfit i believe yeah
yeah that's a great way of explaining it
because i know you studied wushu
taekwondo penchatzilats i was wondering
you know which one are you doing in the
mortal
combat filming you just said ancient
ones can you talk about
fighting in the choreography and like
what all went into that
well um choreography decided of course
we have great choreographers ken griffin
anthony they're amazing
and then they showed me like this is the
fight's gonna be so my job is actually
to put a soul into the fight
to to how fast i'm gonna move which part
that i'm gonna delay which part i'm
gonna stop a sec old
is like the music of the fight you know
and the fight needs to have a rhythm
so if you know the rhythm and then when
you watch the fight it's like you're
listening to the song
it's not just like uh hard all the time
or like
slow or fast it needs to have that all
the combination is to be dynamic
so that's my part as an actor to feel it
with the
with what they when they choreograph
already
so we worked it out and then they were
so supportive
and then we're so open in a process
so well we created a beautiful song
you really did it was amazing did you
play mortal kombat as a child and if so
who what character did you play who was
your favorite to play
i grew up playing mortal of sub-zero but
i gotta be honest i
played scorpion a lot and kung lao
why why because they're so cool i mean
scorpion and like the chain get over
here it's just
it's so iconic in a sentence until now
until it's just iconic and subzero is
almost like
all my friends always say like oh you're
cheating because because you just freeze
me up and opera caught me and i lost
quarter of my health
but i'm in this way this is a skill dog
i mean you cannot really complain
that's why i like to play this character
because i always beat you up
so yeah they're super i mean they're
overpowered characters
that you know you you know for sure that
you will win you when you play
those characters yeah these are your
champions i'm sonya
that's kano josh's first question is for
you because a lot of the comedy that we
get in the movie is through your
character kano so i was wondering
you know how much was on paper and how
much was from you
look uh i definitely got uh freedom to
improvise thanks to
simon mccoy uh you know he would we
would often just put one down scripted
uh which is safe and then say look go
nuts see what comes out and
um and i have an improv background so
you know i was able to lean into that
and it was great and and you know the
other actors were
so up including jess everyone was so
game to play with me
in that and it was it was an opportunity
for me not just to explore the comedy
but also to explore the character
um through improv i'm able to i was able
to really discover who kano was
uh through my eyes so yeah it was um
uh there there was a fair bit of improv
to me i could tell you on from my end
there was a lot of improv like we
never knew what was going to come out of
josh's mouth and uh
it which was really fun but tricky too
because
you know i'm so stoic in this movie and
i have to keep maintain a straight face
and it was
very tricky at times funny is there a
moment that you can tell us that made it
into the film or maybe that didn't make
it into the film
you know where you were uh yeah there
was
multiple moments i remember being in the
middle of the desert when we uh
first meet liu kang and i know there
were a couple of um
like i think he called mchammer there
was definitely like a line there
and then there was just a ton that whole
the whole scene where he gets
his um akana at the dinner table
i mean there are like a multitude of
funny funny one-liners there and we
again well there's that's the first time
where we all actually are meant to be
laughing at his expense so that was
helpful for him to be
off your fighting scenes just like blew
my mind i wanted to talk to the both of
you about
training jess we'll start with you are
you trained for shorts
no i was i'm not and um
i really it's one of the things that
really drew me to this role was that
i've just been desperate to
be an action star from the day i was
born like that's this is kind of my
favorite genre um to play so
um i jumped at the opportunity and i
took every opportunity to train as much
as i could with all of the experts we
had nino pillows and sensei who taught
us so much in martial arts world we had
all of these amazing stunt trainers chan
and
uh my stunt double zia and tara mckinnon
who was also
um cc stringers double like all these
amazing stunt women
that were teaching me how to look like i
knew what i was doing
i literally watching it i was like she
must be trained in martial arts because
that's how i could
part i really want to sleep on it so i
appreciate you saying that
i mean did you get injured at any point
because there there's so much pain
i did i did i hurt my finger when in a
fight where i was training with my stun
double once they got bruises all over me
from all those like wire works
but i also have to give credit to my
amazing stunt double zia kelly who
you know i'm sure there's a couple of
bits in there where she makes me look
extra
good you know tonya blade's such a
badass what about you josh
as a comedian you know how did you go
into the training and tell us more about
that
well yeah as an actor i'm always
thrilled to be able to do new things
right that's like one of the benefits of
of being an actor you get to kind of
sample all sorts of different things in
your life you know as opposed to doing
one job and
you do that forever as an actor you sort
of it's like a little
you know take your pick um and so yeah
this was a great opportunity to do
something i'd never done before and
fighting a martial arts knife work and
uh but you look i didn't really get
injured
that much i had a um i had a little uh
eye injury from a contact lens um
but built that up yeah that's
i am like the least likely person to be
an action hero i swear to god
i'm like i'm like asleep by 9 30 p.m
most nights um with my dog and that's
about it
uh but no look it was great it was great
and ben my stunt double
uh you know looks remarkably like me um
which i'm sure he hates but but no we're
stuck with it
um but yeah he he took a few hits when i
uh
when i was feeling a little fragile
what kind of martial art did you did
each of you have to learn
for your specific character's fighting
style jess let's start with you i
i learnt base stick fighting so um i
learned with these like long bamboo
sticks and it was like all of these
different
um rhythmic kind of patterns that you'd
learn
and then because the knives that i
needed to fight with were so small they
started with something longer
and that was kind of the best way to
kind of hone my skills and coordinate me
with my
both hands working at the same time so
then we went from the sticks to the
knives and then that's kind of where we
stayed obviously because she's a blade
fighter
okay it's more of a brawler right so
he's uh it's a little more
freestyle um kind of based in western
boxing
uh but also knife work but yeah he's
a little more loosey-goosey so not so um
disciplined with the craft
of martial arts you know he's it's he's
had a few beers
you know by the time he fights so he's
he's a bit more
and you know uh he has a bit more fun
with it as opposed to you know saying
like lou kang
or or you know sonya's military
background you know
kano's just like he's a dirty fighter
he's scrappy he'll throw sand in your
face if he gets a cheap shot in i mean
that's the kind of fighter he learned
out of the back of the pub yeah
totally totally in the outback in the
aussie outback you're boxing actual
kangaroos
yeah i got total conor mcgregor vibes
watching kano
yeah yeah we were talking about that
earlier that's so fun
did you guys play mortal kombat growing
up and if so who was your favorite
character to play and why
so i wasn't allowed to play uh my
parents wouldn't
wouldn't let me it was too r-rated um
but i would play at my cousin's house i
would not tell my parents about that um
and i always played sonia
so yeah it's come full circle yeah i
used to
i used to play down at the corner store
in the arcade and uh liu kang was always
my go-to at that point
um but uh that was just because i didn't
i didn't fully understand
kano yeah uh but had i
had i known what a complicated guy he
was i'm sure
he wants very nuanced character he is
very new honest
josh since kano always seems to have an
answer for everything maybe you can tell
us why
mortal kombat is spelled with a k and
not a c
yeah no no no no it's an excellent
question
what would keno think of that well i
would say that um
i would say you know kano would say it's
because of cano
uh it's because uh you know
kano is so such a part of mortal kombat
that you can't spell combat with that
a bit of k a bit of vitamin k um but
yeah i don't know if it's ever explained
in the i know that
you guys referenced in the film the uh
felt wrong i bet it is just something
that kano did to
with everyone just rubbed out just drew
okay
yeah yeah i just couldn't believe it
took off it was like oh
um i just wanted to know if you guys can
give me your best finish ham or finisher
finish it i did it as kano you did it as
kano that was quite good
finish him that was a bad i felt like i
was i feel like i'm getting better at it
kind of wins simon congratulations on
this film
why is this the perfect time to reboot
this franchise and
what shape was the film in when you came
on because i feel like it's been through
a couple iterations
uh well why why now i think the guys at
netherrealm
studios who make the game i think they'd
they've done such an amazing job of
bringing
of evolving this game and just
constantly pushing the envelope and
improving and
i i think perhaps it's probably i'm
standing
on their shoulders really i think
because they've got it to a place where
it's always been part of culture the
sort of
global um culture but it's
but they've really elevated it and moved
and moved it
which allowed it to sort of ask to
springboard and make this sort of
cinematic version of it so
i thank them for that i take no credit
for that at all
the the script itself actually the
framework was there
and the process we went on through
development
and working on the script was really a
question of
of balancing character
bringing one character more into the
movie
bringing this character down a little
bit so it was just this constant
calibration
of making sure the characters were all
being
respected as they should be from day one
i said
this mortal kombat exists and is
successful because of the characters
right if the characters weren't so
uh interesting and powerful and
much loved it just wouldn't be mortal
kombat and then when we started shooting
the realities of shooting sort of
impacted it a little bit
and then you never really stop evolving
and
trying to make it better and better you
just even through post you're always
improving and tweaking and balancing so
but that was the key
key thing about it was about character
well simon you balanced it beautifully
because i feel like we do really get
all the complex characters and they do
have like you know their own shine just
perfectly so i can't wait for the world
to see it what went behind the decision
for the fully r
to just go fully r rating when i
came on board there was no question that
it was going to be done
right we didn't necessarily talk about
what does the rating have to be what we
talked about was
what are the what are the ingredients
and what is the dna of mortal combat
and that has to be respected if we
change
this or that or some fundamentals it was
no longer mortal kombat and it wouldn't
have done it justice so
we knew that that was really important
and we knew that respect and character
and and the music and the brutality of
it was all part of
making up the the whole package of it
and
that was just from day one so i love it
well my favorite character
johnny cage we don't get to see the
infamous johnny
in this film but i wanted to know if
there is a sequel who would you dream
cast in that role
i have no idea
i haven't really put a much thought to
it to be honest because
we we don't we never really talked about
a sequel
whenever anyone did start to mention the
s word on set
i would tell them to stop talking about
that
and say look let's get this right
if we get this right then maybe the fans
will allow us to do a sequel but until
that time
let's not get ahead of ourselves so
we've never really even
talked about it it's never been
mentioned and i don't know to be honest
he's such a complex tricky
big character that
i i haven't even wrapped my head around
that yet i don't know how
that will come about kill them
get over here
you